blade Smith I love pinball this is a
vintage pinball machine so I had to give
it a go especially considering this is
the last game of pinball this machine
will ever see that's because this isn't
just a vintage pinball machine in the
first round of competition today this is
also
your metal good luck blade Smith's your
three hour starts
now the smaller sections of Steel from
the playing field of the pinball machine
that are 5160 yeah the bumpers the first
thing I do I take it over to the chop
saw I don't want to have to deal with
those potential delamination issues
those two bars you need to start heating
up so I'm going back and forth from Big
Blue to the forge with these different
pieces of Steel drawing them out I
forged out the blade to its rough
Dimensions I brought it up to
temperature let it air cool to Black
this helps to kind of cool down the
molecules in the steel so that they take
the quench better
thank you
I pull it out looks pretty darn straight
The Edge hardened right up I think I'm
good
the technique that I'm going to use is a
sand my construction using the piece
from the inside of the pinball machine I
want to sandwich that with the legs on
the outside of the steel I use my angle
grinder and my great big wheel and I
grind off all the scale while my steel
is heating up and the forge I grab the
hydraulic press dies preheat them a
little bit I do two quick presses with
the flat dies to set the welds so I can
make sure that I'm getting that welded
together correctly
Ethan's tapping in the tip on Big Blue
it's a very tricky thing to do
Ethan across the forge with the oxy
acetylene torch the ledge quench I'm
doing an edge quench because I want to
leave that back soft and The Cutting
Edge hard so it'll give the blade more
strength and ideally prevent it from
breaking it's taking me a while because
the Blade's still thicker than I would
normally get it and a lot thicker than I
would like
I'm making a layered construction
recurve fighting knife I'm going to be
doing two layers of leg and two layers
of the bumper to take these two pieces
stick them together and see if I could
Forge all of them to a built watching
his welding there's a lot of squeeze
here and it comes up over here kind of
stuff I I'd be interested to see how
solid these Wells are I don't understand
why I can't get the angles flat
I cannot get this building Square I'm
going to try to solve this by maybe see
if I could flatten it out a little bit
better
I'm using the grinder to get as much of
the surface Material off to thin out the
blade and perhaps even put a little
bevel in there so that I can get it
ready for the quench in this last few
moments what is Steve doing he's gonna
grind himself a knife it's not going to
be pretty it's not going to be shiny but
it sure is going to be done come on
what's that five four three two one
placement drop your tools shut down your
machines this round of competition is
over
blade Smith's congratulations you've
made it into the second round of this
competition now that those blades have
been tempered it's time to turn them
into fully functional weapons by
attaching handles to them so that we can
test them for strength and durability in
a pinball plunger Smash and for Edge
retention in a loop bag slice good luck
your three hour starts
now doing the granding appropriately so
I don't screw myself over it it's kind
of hard that one Puck Mark there is now
going away so at this point leave it
alone
by the thickness that I have left I
can't afford to take off any more
material so I'm calling it good
with my grinding done it's time to move
on to my handle which means I need to
get holes into my tank
I drill holes in my Tang but the fit is
not ideal
so I have to drill a little bit more to
make them less of an issue for the
sharpness test I'm gonna put a wicked
Edge on there but it can't be too thin
because for the pinball plunger smash it
has to be strong enough I don't want my
Edge to roll over or chip as soon as I
finish sharpening on the grinder I get a
wet stone and a piece of leather that I
can strop with just making sure that
edge is polished and really sharp my
blade is very sharp there is very little
hair on my forearm now this blade it
will shave my first priority is going to
be a handle because if it doesn't have a
handle they're not going to be able to
test it at all
materials I decided to use for my handle
construction is a piece of brass for the
guard and a piece of white oak wood it's
like white oak the guard was not a
parameter but my opinion the best way to
protect the person using it needed a
guard
the clock is ticking down
so I start profiling my handle I'm going
for a fighter style shape it's going to
take that one inch contact wheel and
Contour the handle and the guard all in
one shot and make it seamless I intend
to have a palm swell and a thinner spot
down where your pinky and ring finger
would be so that your hand would fit
really nicely to the handle
like what Ethan did to the back of that
handle really nice work
finishing up the handle to make a tour
it would fit in my hand I don't know if
it'll work for the judge's hands but I
can't use their hands so that's all I
got I have a lot of delaminations seeing
if I can even things out and get it
ready for a handle I have to keep
checking it to make sure it's not
thinning out the blade too much
so Steve how has drilled four holes in
his tank and then freehand drilled them
through the wood
the odds of all poles lining up
perfectly are very small I've chosen the
Courtney bolts that have two pieces to
them and I'm going to put them through
the holes and get them to connect in the
center I need to get the final Edge on
it I have got to get this thing done I'm
feeling anxious I know I'm going to get
it done but it may not be quite good
enough
five five four three two one
bladesmiths shut down your machines
is over hello blade Smiths welcome to
the strength test to test the strength
and durability of your Edge as well as
the overall construction of your blade
I'll be launching that 52 100 nine pound
pinball at the edge of your knives three
times Steve you're up first you ready
ready
foreign
I like the shape of your blade I like
the forward bend to it but the pinball
did some damage there's some rolls up
here at the edge
there's also some gapping here at the
handle in the back and and in the front
but it all held up well done thank you
all right Ethan you're up next you ready
I suppose you suppose well I suppose I'm
gonna do it
[Music]
all right
well Ethan first things first it did
take some rolling
the handle is a little bit big there's a
lot of handle left over on this knife
but I love how you relieved all the uh
all the grinds on your guard here
beautiful knife thank you Michael you're
up you ready I am
foreign
you have the most flexible of the blades
that are out there it ended up that
flexibility gave you a little advantage
in this test because the edge rolling
that's here it's and there is some it's
not bad well done thank you
bladesmiths this is the loot bag slice
to test the edge of your blade I will
take your weapon and I will slash on
these loot bags empty and liberating the
prices in there now unlike the strength
test this is all about what the edge of
your blade will do to these loot bags
Steve you're up first you ready I'm
ready
thank you
[Music]
all right see as you can see in slicing
this bag it just cuts on the impact area
on the slice itself it didn't cut the
bag open
Steve sell your bladeser did not really
cut
Ethan your attorney ready
I suppose
all right Ethan suck about your handle
here the swell you have there makes my
hand go only in one spot where it's
comfortable but because you have such a
large handle if you go to other spots it
gets in the way now your Edge as you can
see it cuts in every movement it
liberated the contents which allows me
to say your blade sir will cut
thank you all right Michael your turn
you ready oh yeah
Steve's knife struggled with the loot
bag slice he seems obliterated the bag
I'm feeling a little bit nervous
first up your Edge is sharp enough to
cut this loot bag open it feels good in
the hand it was easy to move around with
your blade and overall sir your blade
will cut
blade Smiths the judge's deliberation is
complete it's time for one of you to
leave the forge the blade Smith leaving
the forge is
Steve your blade didn't make the cut
Steve all the blades to the same kind of
amount of damage during the strength
this but the sharpness test your blade
just didn't cut and for that reason
we're sending you home
Steve please surrender your blade
great experience I was able to not only
see other Smiths at work but also to
push my own limits
I have learned some things here and I'm
going to take them to my own shop and I
may just make another six hour night